[Evans] To get our outputs in the correct range,
we're going to use the modulus operator.
This is written with a percent sign.
It's usually the Shift 5 on most keyboards.
What modulus does is takes a number and maps it to the range
based on the remainder when you divide that number.
The way modulo arithmetic works is like a clock,
so if we think of having a clock with 12 hours
and then arithmetic on the clock is modulo 12.
If we were to evaluate 14 % 12, what that would mean is if you start from 0
and we make 14 steps--we're going to go 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12, 13, 14--
where we end up is 2.
That's the same as the remainder we would get by dividing 14 by 12,
and that's the result of 14 % 12 is 2.
So now we're going to have a few quizzes
to make sure that you understand the modulus operator
as well as the ord and chr operators we introduced.